the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club hello and welcome
back to the finals of the protest League
summer series my name is Caleb Denby I'm
joined as I was yesterday by the
wonderful international master dorsa
Derek ishani
and we're here to give you the coverage
over the match against the South Paulo
capybaras in st. Louis Archbishop's
hi-yah it will be very interesting match
because from what I've heard those are
well actually personally for me it's a
very interesting match because my team
is playing against one of the Iranian
super grandmasters the future and it's
very interesting for me since I've known
him since I was it was a kid and well
it's still a kid but yeah it's very
interesting for me personally to see how
the Archbishop's will play against this
team and especially this player but yeah
yeah it was certainly a difficult road
to get here last night we did coverage
over the big match against the chengdu
pandas and then this morning we actually
took out the chess prize in crushing
style we wanted something like ten and a
half to five and a half yeah I've heard
about it but I it's would be very
interesting if we could see those games
too but it was very early morning guys
yeah so yeah thanks to the players for
getting up so early to get the job done
there and your apologies to the chest
prize so I'm sure struggled struggled
with the early morning round I believe
some of the chess prez also reside in
st. Louis I'm not sure which ones but
yeah I think they spend a lot of time in
st. Louis they haven't a house here I
think but I to my knowledge they're all
in Canada for the moment oh all right
yeah this is really interesting game so
do you have em going up for yeah so our
lineup as always is a super Grandmaster
Fabiana Cara wanna on board one super
Grandmaster Wesley so on board two
international master Nicholas Theodore
ooh on board three and then finally
national master Josh bloomer on board
four and going up against it's a pretty
tough lineup board one for Sao Paulo is
Sandra Mariko who is a twenty six
hundred plus VJ rated Grandmaster board
to actually is the now over 2700 Alireza
Perugia so that'll be some interesting
matchups to see there yeah board three
is Creek or Mecca tarean who is twenty
five fifty rate of Grandmaster
and then finally on board for is a
national master Lukas Cardozo rounding
out the lineup for Sao Paulo so it's
gonna be interesting to see how these
players stack up I think you know as we
usually do will have advantages on board
one in board two and so it'll really
come down to how many points can Josh
bloomer score it's a really put us over
the yeah but last night he did a
fantastic job yeah absolutely
in the last round I believe he he played
a really beautiful game well most i from
what I remember he played beautiful game
every every man is yeah yeah he just
couldn't finish up the job but the last
round he did and it's it's very
interesting to see for for us and
hopefully who managed to do the same
things again well more points but the
the same beautiful chess that's we saw
right yeah no he ran in some
difficulties there a lot of winning
positions yeah not he's not able to
convert in the in the time pressure it
can be very difficult so we're just
waiting here for the games to get
started
looks like chess talk homes still
getting everything set for the moment so
what are your predictions what do you
think the final score is gonna be fun
well obviously I want the Archbishop's
to win and the more points the better
but I do think it will be a very close
close call for the anyone who wins it
will be a very close call
so my prediction is that we will win but
just one point yeah just just by one
point interesting no from what I know
that we don't have to draw outs so right
it I think it's my knowledge that
there's a tie-break going to be played
if we do tie that in the
match so I'm not entirely sure on the
exact format for that but so we'll cross
that bridge if we come to it I don't
think we're gonna get that far I think
we're gonna definitely crush Sao Paulo I
don't know how close it's gonna be but
the only a kind of wild card I think is
Perugia on on board - yes the speed
chess specialist and while this is kind
of rapid time controls it still is a lot
faster than a lot of these players are
used to and freesia will probably be
right at home playing on the internet
and playing with that Oh actually this
is interesting because I've heard a lot
of rumors about him trying to move to
France oh wow so I don't know how true
they are cuz I'm not personal in touch
with him but if that is true and she
switches Federation's to friends that'll
we I believe that's a very good stepping
stone for him she might be the next
mixing hero to French players in
sinkhole Cup or some stuff like that it
was very interesting to to see that girl
especially since he's so young I I'm not
sure exactly how young but I know I
believe oh we have a game starting yeah
something like 17 18
yeah that's does this around the age
yeah it looks like a couple games have
started I'm taking like Josh bloomers
game three games started so Josh women's
games started it's a 45 Thank You Josh
for your each foot and they started they
are playing Cillian defense could you
well I'm so sorry could you one more
time remind me of Josh's opponent and
racing josh is playing board one for
South Paulo who is Sandra Mariko just
like the the username says and he is 26
30
fidei yes great us what we want off the
heart games for Josh
yeah the board for versus board one
matchups are always going to be tough
yeah but I personally like the opening
that stay played it's it's very
interesting to see this sort of palm
structures I believe it's it's not a
hard hard game to play because as whites
and I'm assuming also black you know
what you're doing in your position
you're going to try to push the deep on
if you're going to you
thank you you're going to bring the
bishop out and hopefully if there will
be no exchange on d4 you'll have some
stuff ideas with 92 and nf1 and bring
you the night to the other side of the
board if there won't be a CD for 64 so
yeah that's let's keep it the classic c3
Sicilian yeah this is well this but this
should be five but yeah it's I I I
really like this this kind of openings
that you know what you're doing you
don't have to keep thinking about crazy
lines it's picking up where these crazy
lines I keep remembering puppy on his
games
again it's mixing this year I believe it
was a missing foot cup yeah that's it
was very deep preparation and it was
neither of opening and yeah we were
making a joke that we should start
calling the client the Fabiano line for
the car one on line so see how well that
what is what is probably up to today
yeah I was just going to look at that
all right
efore again I'm so glad to see we have
[Music]
some sort of a Sicilian con but it
wasn't the most straightforward since 93
was played first but it's interesting
yeah but it's a transposition and yeah I
don't I can't really recall any recent
games of Fabi playing this set up the
black but these are just very
interesting because again the players
know what they're doing and specially in
Sicilian calm there could be some really
sharp lines that's you but whites would
have to look out for but I know for a
Sicilian con is that the move d5 would
be a very dangerous it would be the
lookouts for broke either sides so yeah
this would be an interesting game I do
want to check on let's look at the
Weslie so game first because he's our
second board absolutely
their third yes yeah these are these are
the key matchups in the arms line it's
the board to against the board three my
prediction for this round is probably
will win
listen might have a little bit of
difficulty but she should be able to win
the game especially because in well yeah
I'm not sure I think this position looks
pretty pleasant for black actually but
yeah it is very pleasant for black but I
don't really see any clear I don't I
can't really um yeah I would like to
just play something like Queen a6 yeah
kind of in vain what I'm thinking about
is so I would want this night to be
placed somewhere like c4 or be more
active than what it is but I don't
really think that's going to happen in
the game and that might be really
frustrating because let's say you want
to improve your night so look first of
all the moves I move like b5 shouldn't
really be played and unless you
absolutely have to select I do agree we
do move such as Queen e6 I'm trying to
play replace maybe yeah there's there
might be a problem with between a 6
though and in the move b5 oh yes a 7
just to have the protection on the b6
pond right so maybe you can free after
nights but yeah I would be even tempted
to play oh well rip yeah it is
interesting
so you might be considering taking on c5
I know that file
my question is if bc 5 would white want
to take bc 5 or DC fun because if you
take DC 5 then this bishop will be quite
strong on a 8h 8 a 1 diagonal but if you
don't take it if you play like say bc 5
mm take back would be then good because
then the pawns on the Queen side are
symmetrical with that actually favored
black or white that's what I'm trying to
um in general I think this that would
favor white because white doesn't really
have a lot of prospects of playing a 5
in this position yeah and that seems
like the classical way to attack the c5
pawn try to undermined through a 3d
floor with his 85 break yes
um I feel like that this one is going to
be an unpleasant match for Leslie
especially because he would I'm sure
you'd prefer to have what's a position
that is so yeah it's something wildly
unbalanced
yeah yeah this Oh what happened in
Bobby's game so we left that somewhere
here and they were talking about the
ideas with d5 well they decided to play
d65
so interesting that's also one of the
other ideas because now that's your
bishop is Alton c5 instead of being an
e7 then you're you want to free your
LightSquared bishop and it makes perfect
sense so I also believe that so we do
see Knight f5 and the immediate capture
yes and I honestly like this her black
because wait actually
[Music]
so I don't know it seems like an
interesting position in the central
White has this nice light squared bishop
and black has the two nights obviously
but black has gained an advantage in the
center so I think if I can get the move
defy yeah yeah that's quite nice so that
means that Y should start thinking the
mods push to something like the ship c4
yeah I would consider maybe Bishop f3 as
well and just trying to put my knight on
d5 and and claiming that you can never
really gained control of this clay also
fabi's like five minutes off on time
yeah so this is something we've seen
from probably actually is playing some
wild and kind of crazy line and then
just being a fun time this is nowhere
near what you play that Maxine yeah it's
yeah let's let's take a quick look on
theories ja and Nicholas
yeah I'm Nicola says this is definitely
one of the tougher matchups this round
for what is going on here uh so this
looks like a kings in the end so let's
take a quick look all right everything
normal so far so good
just following theory developing your
pieces yeah this guy like this idea of
it nice a 1.e4 I'm not I'm not an expert
in this opening but it looks like it
looks very natural to me so the bishop
here is quite strong and you want it to
be replaced right so no yet this this
makes a lot of sense obviously white
goes for the the central advantage in
this case with the fianchetto on g2 it's
a little more conservative than the
classic alliance where what kind of just
tries to check me at white the bishop
provides a lot of defense only but then
black ministry makes so much sense and i
see - just trying to relocate the night
mm-hmm
controlling the nice d4 square so that
after d5 you know the knight never has
the option and the others think the
other thing to think about is so after
the light squared bishop tsar exchange
so you can see this as white this slight
square the light square bishop wouldn't
be the best since we in all of the pawns
are placed in light squared
light squares right so it's a good idea
for I believe White's you have that's
bishop exchange and especially in King's
Indian attacks this Bishop on D said the
white color light colored bishop would
be really annoying for white now that
that's exchanged it will be interesting
to see if fevers joy can actually make
an attack out of this yeah so furger she
goes for this f6 and i assume an f5 to
follow yes that the classical throne
storm on the Kings side then how is
Nikolas going to find counterplay I
guess with yeah yeah there are a lot of
things to try out in the queen sized for
white but I'm trying to figure out what
could be the most efficient way to stop
blacks attack in the King sign and then
start to clean side would it be a better
idea to start marching on the Queen side
while looking at the at the pawn breaks
the black heads I'm not so sure that
black is really threatening to break
through your game that is played for I'm
simply going to play G yeah and if you
do play g5 and g4 I think maybe F takes
G for and you're not really getting
enough open files
I think Nikolas has the kingside under
control and he goes for the Queen
exchange which would make so much sense
especially because when they're when if
the Queen's are exchanged off the board
and the this attack won't have that much
it won't be as worrying I want to say
but before is actually it strikes me
it's kind of an odd move depends on how
how would black try to respond to it
because also another move to consider it
is let's say a long run may if there is
g5 ever played when the Queen if the
Queen makes it to g6 it could be a
little annoying and the way to do that
would be with Queen EA twin g6 reporter
to relocate a knight and Queen f7 Queen
g6 and so I can understand why Queen a4
then you are
eliminating Ulta options with Queen e8
interesting yeah to me it looks as
though like usually the Queen's a very
nice defender of the King and so it's
kind of far away on the Queen side but I
guess it's trying to remove the black
Queen can play as well yes um so it's
just
let's just hope Nikolas won't forget
about this Queen and d3 b6 they are all
mmm
wait this is trying to make something
with 96 um that must be it b6 of course
weakens the square yeah but I don't want
to see if the purpose of the knight on
c6 it looks definitely looks really nice
but is it as useful as it looks
um yeah I would have liked to see
something like you know the classic B 4
and C 5 yeah well if that before C 5
idea happens now then it's going to be
way more stronger since there won't be a
topi 8 or 88 so that's definitely if
that happens is it's going to give so
much more meaning to 90 c6 but Queen c2
f4 was played on a board g4 so Oh
walking up yeah I didn't expect to go
for this now the only way to break
through for black is really going to be
with a sacrifice something like Knight
takes g4
I agree but what if there is a Street
played and then H 3 H 5 and now Nikolas
plays Queen d1 as you mentioned earlier
the Queen is a nice defender of the King
and it's a good idea to have it around
so yep and this is specifically aimed
against you know stuff like Knight takes
g4 I think that's really the only way
but can can try to go for a check maker
it's something like that so yeah King of
7 is anticipating the opening of the h5
idea of the drop a shades I'm most
likely Queen g8 and bringing this the
pieces the heavy pieces towards the King
side mhm
we should be one is a nice move but was
it necessary to play B should be one I'm
thinking is there any way that the
knight could be more useful um possibly
I think this is a common idea is just to
put this Bishop on f2
where it is the Queen
so quite nicely and it also again defend
some key square I'm thinking is it's a
crazy idea to take my king and just
bringing this to the Queen side um
definitely not a crazy idea but at the
same time one once you kind of put this
King on the Queen side then suddenly
it's a little it's a little more
difficult the plane moves like before
and see fo that is correct
I wanted to say a quick hello to all the
viewers here
jean-bob ler cheesy chess borracho fan
and new devil's 101 while watching the
stream in the chat I'm good to see you
guys thank you for joining us
of course this is the finals of the
protest League summer series were
squaring off against the South Pole
capybaras and we're hoping to take home
the trophy they're playing really fast
it's so this idea with bishops f2 was
played and this honestly worries me a
little because I'm never going to have
the idea to try and bring the King to
the Queen's and Queen side so I hope
that's I hope I'm wrong actually I don't
know I've played a lot of positions like
this and I mean usually I end up
checkmated but I think Nikolas please
next change and you got the sacrifice
that you want it's interesting now the
question is is it actually don't know if
I wanted it the problem seems to be
stuff like like f3 yeah yeah one more
second to just see where it started to
go wrong hmm yeah it looks very
impressed might be a situation where she
takes h5 is actually required
I'm just preventing this nice sacrifice
honestly I still like the idea bringing
my king to the other side yeah I want to
play something like GT h5 and then it
takes h5 and then rook a g1 just
preparing to extract that king yes this
is definitely going to be a very
unpleasant game for Nikolas if not
losing um so what's the what's the
winning line for black I feel like you
surely have to take this night yes
how does black win I think it's f3 is
simply f3 in the night off for check
seems yes not checkmating yes especially
because where would you go with your
King G 1 this one is rook is hanging up
the Queen's defending it but you cannot
play King g3 because of registry and
then that's what be maids so yeah that's
why this is actually just losing this
pawn then yeah not the best of the best
of course this is one of the toughest
matchups for a side point - yes um let's
take a look at the other games quickly
so we have a better idea of sure how
you're doing on the match looks like
it's Bobby's game ah this one game looks
very this thing this is winning in him
right this is it must be yeah rooks are
worth more than bishops that's not my
sexist but um and they're drooping on
the second rank is very strongly placed
so so what happens at c7 here do we take
the bishop board no wait what do we play
if we take the bishop you make a queen I
take take and then um well actually it
is it should be good enough because I
can just take on 8a for the s1 Falls as
well yeah which isn't incredibly
important yeah c7 but if you don't play
c7 as what then what would we do um
exactly I think c7 regains the exchange
by force but unfortunately the the rock
end game seems to be losing yeah
Bobby notices and games he'll be fine
and he all he has so much more time how
yeah how is Wesley doing this seems like
it's going to be like the key game for
the matchup so Wesley did get this Queen
to c4 I was going for it still looks
quite unpleasant for both sides actually
oh so white went for this f4 to f5 move
so this releases some control over the
e5 square but it does make some some
pretty key weaknesses in blacks camp
here I also feel like especially since
whistle has so much more time this might
be one of those game sets
and time of trouble whistle is gonna
pull something up that's not the best
moment right then whites with the
crossword well for it so this is an
interesting position here yeah but if
you recapture on e6 what is white going
to play because this night is kind of
hanging if you play a queen g6 which
seems naturally I think I'd like to just
play Knight to f6
Oh knight of fate no yeah that would
just be winning actually I think so what
if some move like if fe6 and you would
just play okay actually can you buy just
something like a 15-3 yeah rook d3 it
and maybe then is the right moment to
open the B file yeah take bc v since you
can't believe this c5 and the rook would
be you there works would be exchanged
and then a nice hanging so many pins
yeah I I like this yeah I don't know if
I like this decision to play f5 by white
because now after f e6 there's also all
sorts of ideas of black playing E 5 at
the correct moment I feel like we left
it up somewhere around actually they
left it up somewhere around here yeah
after with me 8 Jesus yeah we let's talk
about G 3 him so little so few moves
have been played since we laughter laugh
26
it's a transposition I feel like this is
this is a very big decision to make and
actually yeah why it's spent about three
and a half minutes thinking about this
position right now and what he also
spend equally three minutes deciding on
Queen c4 and fe6 also took another three
minutes Wesley took back right now and I
I'm still trying to figure it out I'm
not sure what white is doing I guess
like Queen East 7 valid oak we need two
valid cuz i'm still have the ideas of
taking and 9f8 is not interesting
happening anymore
oh yeah Queen e2 might be something see
I don't think taking the knight can be
correct so I could play a simple move
like Queen takes Queen and then B takes
e5 perhaps I think yeah that seems like
the most logical approach so if I take
on a two
can't see it the Queen takes Knight
takes and then maybe BC five and when
you recapture I would trade rooks and
probably play e5 to try and break and
challenge the c5 fun okay the wonderful
tots I've just joined us in the studio
for a moment and she dropped off what
seems to be a cat spin fun stuff I mean
I have a I have a big love for cats
I'm dogs but I only cats toss-up just
gave me yeah captain if that's wonderful
yeah I wanted to say a quick hello to
Hakim 5050 and Grandmaster JJ who is
watching in the chatroom so Queenie to
was played but it also costs another two
minutes for whites definitely that's
going to be a very relevant factor yeah
actually Queenie to maybe five
immediately at well I'm sorry the Queen
exchange and then II five would be
something to look for they're black I
feel like Queen you to has to be played
I don't really see any other options for
black but at the same time oh I believe
they're actually see three Queenie six
and then maybe
King h8 just to step out of everything
Stefan's really interesting I can't see
why
[Music]
perhaps I move like I really want to say
nice nice II thought 95 min take take
and you're still taking these seven and
you're attacking the eight but it's a
full piece so maybe actually the
unconventional Queen e6 King h8 and the
night II one and then it's just a fork
you're just attacking both the bishop in
the night and it's tough to save both
pieces yeah but in that scenario I'm
just I still want to sacrifice something
I'm thinking maybe you're give ease sure
you have to put pressure on f2 but
cleaning seven and you still second
decent oh yeah my t1 is definitely a
very nice move definitely a lot to think
about you can kind of see why I got so
low on time here yeah I think this is
this is the right piece for Wesley to
really kind of sink in and find the
correct line yeah I also don't think
there is I don't think either of them
are any real danger but they you had to
have to be able to find the precise
moves because a lot of a lot of the
pieces and pawns are just under attack
so they can't sort of hanging pieces
Nikko's certainly a lot has happened
since or less yeah both so fast so
that's still we're somewhere here right
yeah black one this keep on but you know
white does get this c5 break-in this is
that something for ya some counterclaim
but I I just don't know if it's enough
counter play because it looks very
beautiful and you have so many ideas if
you take a seven then b6 falls right but
at the same time this is um yeah like g4
is coming in its but yeah these nerves
of steel to play like this with what the
problem is Nikolas has to make a
decision either he has to go for the
blood over here and
get into an unpleasant attack on his
King side or there's no way he can
defend it since the g4 pond is fallen so
it makes sense what Nikolas is doing it
makes sense under the circumstances okay
but also I'm thinking why did he call us
take it to the scene I try not to this
night yeah that would have been a lot
more natural in my opinion or even
taking with the Queen I agree yeah just
exchange your Queens if you can
interesting yeah that seems like a very
strange decision to me I'm always
offering Queen trades whenever I can and
lines like this
I want to catch up to the live game to
see how is it going so Nikolas gots this
two pawns but he also got another nice
sacrifice Monti accepted the sacrifice
in this situation clean u5o no Queen
this looks quite dangerous
Queenie what is coming things like efore
and III are coming it's it's looking
kind of unpleasant it does I I don't
know how Disney coulis is going to
survive this it's I I think it it's
possible to say that that he's not going
to survive this one yeah definitely
definitely
I don't know like you can mess this up
if your fridge is still you have to find
the right line the checkmating line but
I think that the game's well and hinges
you hear all right let's take a quick
look on how fabi's doing it oh this is a
Vanagon game I find if I don't want to
son game then all of my coaches combined
will be super disappointed in me so
what's the winning idea um well you try
to push this rook away and the thing is
the King should be in g3 because when
you do get to push the rock away there
or they could be what I'm trying to say
you can never play idea that king of
drinking before or King HD for that
matter cuz you get to check so your King
has very few squares to go the only h2
and maybe f2 but even if you
every dupe waking up so you can never
touch the Jeep on because Rakesh want
ideas with Turkish too so here white
can't really make any progress so it
gives black the perfect opportunity to
come and try to hunt the f5 pond so how
do you actually win the f5 pond now why
does it might just keep the rock on a5
so if you're say so you were saying
something with King before King aged
well if King gave student you get King
if to king f4 to take away squares from
oh we have a results yeah looks like
fusion did find a way to win this one
Wow and ended up with two queens on the
board how did this happen they play so
fast so we left it off somewhere around
here we get faint
Queens for it should be one Queen d3 oh
yeah yeah that battle that'll get the
job done
yeah this was definitely one of the
toughest matches for Nikolas so she
played a good game he tried to play
create some contra play but so let's
assume Bobby can win that endgame yes
what's going on in the other game I want
to take a look at Josh's game because we
only looked at the opening briefly
what's this
I don't think Josh can actually make
something happen in this sent game yeah
this looks very tough he has a Roquefort
for the two nights and I believe yeah
the pawns are equal and so obviously the
two nights aren't you know the two minor
pieces you would pick given you given
your choice of any of them but in this
case they're actually doing quite a lot
there's a lot of squares for them to hop
into yeah and the inclusion of this dark
squared bishop just josh is one minutes
to four minutes and it's yeah I I'm not
very optimistic about this match either
so I guess it's all down to Wesley then
Wesley into it to win this game in order
to so we left it off summer
dc3 oh so what's the display the queen
seat read the table
considering Queen six King h8 has you
set you geniuses oh yeah right 291
that's yeah Kirk it's you that is not a
move that I was considering but I think
it's very similar to you right yeah just
a different order fades I wanted to play
Rico fate first but you'll miss me so 93
to defend the f2 pond Queen D for
putting more pressure on of to pond
Queen d7 was played huh this interesting
so checkmate yeah that's definitely what
it seems nice sacrifice and then how do
you put the finishing touches on can you
do you have time to play h5 simply to
play h5 now just do it all with check or
something like oh yeah
Oh Queen e2 and then if the King comes
back to h3 there's Queen H 5 min yes yes
and King h4 is the same story after g5
and then I guess King f5 there's Queenie
4
so he looks like this match is going to
be its sure to just check mate in all
lines so esli is definitely going to win
this skin meetin - I trust that he can
find it what's Fabio - Papa's game so oh
wow
this is not what I expected to see I
well the thing is wise can't really take
on it 82 candy because you just get
tricky to rights so we just retreats but
now yet with this rep on the side of the
pond
now the the path is kind of cleared you
come over yeah I copy you probably got
this
I'll see if I want to keep my focus ah
oh he's checked meeting him that's very
mean that's very mean go Fabi so 22
confirmed all the games have actually
wrapped up no Josh didn't end up losing
in that end game which was kind of
expected but yeah the 2800 Scott got the
job done this time thank you Wesley and
Fabi yeah you're definitely kind of a
crazy rounds
this was a really hard to predict well
actually it wasn't that hard but I had I
had more hopes for this game a very
pleasant position he was playing on the
opening in the middle game well I think
yeah I still can't figure out where he
started going wrong I'm stealing
somewhere around here he started to play
a little too slow yes this Queen c2 and
then Queen d1 obviously looks a little
bit strange maybe the Queen should have
just come to d1 immediately
I agree probably deficits but also I
still don't understand it could I
actually simply just bring my king to
the Queen side yeah I think that seems
reasonable even just bringing the king
to like d3 would be a lot safer than
yeah because there's you can say the
best you could do is probably put your
knight on c5 and I can always have to
ieave before even if you play a five
okay I have an eye on c6 and I don't see
five well just those hangouts it's not
it's not the end of the world but right
the I feel like Nikolas underestimated
the attack in the Kings side otherwise
he would have plates he's came to the
Queen side or at least prepared better
for the attack yeah I think he just
underestimated blacks threats on the on
the Kings side it looks like he had
everything pretty well under control
with this Queen on d1 defend against the
sac on g4 but the tactics just didn't
seem to work out for him
yeah I agree I'm also thinking would it
make a good idea for him to if let's say
instead of Queen c2 he did play Queenie
d1 and then Queen let's say eat you
yeah could you could you point ninety
one night f2 to just cover more squares
and especially H Street and then tried
to play her katana would he have enough
time yeah I don't I think this listen I
don't have to is another defensive setup
that white uses quite a lot so it that
would make a lot of sense to me
I actually I think I was a bit too harsh
on Queen c2 it kind of forced blacks
hands to play f4 so I think that move
actually makes a lot of sense all right
but but so how yeah even here I think
like ninety one would be a
very nice man yes unless the immediate
sacrifices possible mm-hmm so maybe
start with H 3 H 3 is 5 and then he
played Queen D 1 could he actually my
question is quickly Bishop you want I
think it was really just concerned with
the immediate sacrifice its h6g 4 and
then Knight takes G for us it looks kind
of dangerous so because he played 21 I'm
gonna Queenie to later on and I was
trying to just place my queen on eating
you deeply see I would have liked to see
Queenie to here and then 91 2 F 2 rather
than Bishop Yvonne I think this Bishop
Rima nuvaring didn't I that's that's
someone that I don't understand because
you could you could still try to play
with Queen e2 but he can never play
knife to it again cuz I've denied h4
checks so I'm not so sure that NH 4 it
is totally a huge problem with your
Queen honey - on your Knights on f2
obviously I would like to have King f1
be legal and in that case but maybe that
is a problem I don't know I guess maybe
black had more threats than we were
giving him credit for it there's some
very concrete problem safer way okay
great so we're back to my idea of
running away with the king yeah I guess
Nikolas um yeah he just popped in it to
say hello yeah so JJ can I will my kinks
to the Queen yes in some professional
advice here yeah it's it's definitely an
interesting match to watch well to to
was the expected result so could you
tell me the lineups for the next rounds
because I think next rounds so yeah I
believe Fabi would be playing board 3
which is GM crack or I believe Wesley is
going to be playing board for next I'm
not a hundred percent sure on that so
that would be Lucas Cardoso and then
Josh would have to square off against
ali reza
that leaves Nicholas to play against
Sandro mareko aboard one for self hello
okay so it's definitely another
interesting match I wanted to say that I
do remember a while ago when was it a
few months ago and tournament in Germany
I believe I might be a little off future
lost to a 1900s it was right before he
crossed 2,700 and so I'm just saying
it's not it could happen yeah
but yes it's very easy to drop games
especially in a format like this that is
the tournament that's there were a lot
of controversies about so he was paired
again so he still presents Iranian
Federation and he was paired against an
Israeli opponents in the tournament I
believe it was in Germany again I could
be wrong well and then he refused to
play because that's actually a different
for a different time about why Iranians
are not supposed to play against right
but and that's almost that's not down to
the person but that's kind of submissive
role set set out by the Federation I
chose to play against Israel mm-hmm and
so my brother brother also happens to
play against Israel so but three boats
we don't play for International
Federation anymore I play for us and my
brother plays through England but so
yeah that's was and I believe that the
that psychology also affected fear was
just tournaments and that's and it's
Germany tournaments I guess because he
then he didn't he couldn't show up on
the board and then she lost to 1900 but
yeah it was a interesting to know yet so
looking forward to to the next rounds
what he expects to happen in the next
round another two to result with the top
boards winning in the bottom boards
losing I think that's the expected one
but I have more feet in Nicholas yeah
here we see that the game actually got
started I think this is the matchup to
watch because I I don't want to insult
anybody but I think Sandra Merrik
was kind of bored one in name only I
think Elly Raisa is really the toughest
opponent here I really especially he had
a very very good year last year and he
managed to cross and sound under it so
absolutely so I think this is the chance
for a Nicolas de chartes going upset why
do we keep getting Kings India I don't
know it's certainly interesting in my
it's almost the exact same line that was
saw last time but black is taking a
little bit of a different approach here
going for bringing this Knight to c5
there's a little like karma is telling
Nikolas you just what you just lost you
can get back all right all right I'm
gonna leave this game to watch Bobby's
game and so what is going on here we
have Roy Lopez opening Oh Spanish
opening and some people would say forgot
Berlin I'm sure Bobby has excellent
preps and Berlin's especially yeah so
yeah it's I was watching the simple
commentary since I've been here as the
dream resident since right before
thankful started and I saw I've been
watching him and it's I I see the
players interview and a lot of them are
very honest about how they forgot their
openings or they couldn't find that one
they couldn't remember that one specific
move that's they prepare them they're
there they were really proud of Brett so
one thing that I was like the everybody
to know is that yeah chess players even
the supervisors do mess up their lines
so yeah it's just it's kind of
ridiculous how much openings that
they're expected to remember yeah so
it's gotten to the point where they they
just can't I was thinking so in the
medical fields there are some people who
genetically can have a photographic
memory
right so like and those would be like
this super super like thin so poppy Diaz
that go to med school and they remember
everything so I don't think this is
something that's been said about Magnus
right he can remember like almost every
chess game he's looked at he can
remember
data was played and who the players were
what the tournament was what the
tournament situation was so remember all
these details about travel chess games
I'm saying like if somebody who does
have a photographic memory play plays
chess and why stress on has the interest
to an ambitious to actually want to be a
good chess player I feel like that's
going to be someone that Magnus has to
watch her yeah for sure yeah listen 94
moves pretty interesting and kind of
dares black to play f5 trying to kick
the night away but then I think that
might be met with the Queen b3 just to
put pressure on this no I I feel like
Bob is very comfortable in this position
especially since she got to played the
moves that he wanted to she got his
bishop relocated to a better position
and he he managed to gain more space in
the Queen side and she placed his knight
in the I want to say the best position
imaginable in this game and she does
have two ideas Queen b3 definitely and
they could also be some ideas with
Bishop g5 coming up maybe yeah
if the bishop were to come to e6 the
Knight g5 absolutely yes
that's annoying yeah I agree these days
look this looks like a comfortable
mattress from B Hugh should be able to
get the job done in this man nice let's
take a look at the Restless game mm-hmm
so I think this is another critical
matchup here is Wesley really needs to
get the job done against these lower
rated players on Sao Paulo all right so
we have Italian opening to all of it
Italian viewers yeah we have the typical
stuff here just bringing the Knights and
nitrogen I believe that's they also
played another Italian against the law
writ up yesterday so yeah this is
something that uh I think it took a lot
of the top grandmasters that are doing a
lot nowadays I don't know if they're
tired of the Berlin or anything like
that but the Italian seems to be what
they play to try to get an advantage in
a classical time controls at least yeah
[Music]
ah this looks like it comfortable this
is very no less let's got this
yeah his pieces look very nice blacks
pieces look a little bit out over time
yeah disjoints yeah a little bit
uncomfortable yeah this is um I believe
this that's got it let's take another
look for why don't I don't think this
took we looked at spheres just game
again so yeah you really have to feel
for the lower rate of players in these
lineups round one play board one around
to play board two it's it's really
difficult to uh so I don't maybe
maintain composure when you're getting
crushed by these amazing chess players
but maybe Josh Willa will do something
surprising as we saw yesterday he
managed to play beautiful chess all
rounds and he gots you gotta win up the
last round so I have faith in Josh he
can make it happen
but um it's just got to be intimidating
so what was your first game that is the
up against le Reza no I'm trying to
understand so this opening is a really
sharp opening for Josh to play against
ali riza especially since he's the lower
rated I'm trying to understand wouldn't
it be better idea to play something a
little less aggressive yeah possibly I
think especially against Persia
specifically knowing that he's like so
tactically sharp compared to almost any
other player in the world but I guess it
goes back to that philosophy do you want
to play a crazy game against a higher in
a player or do you want to try to play
solid and hope they don't find a way to
win yeah that's a tough dilemma they're
playing so fast we're never gonna catch
up wow so this a five great yeah
I don't know if this is a theory that I
don't know about they're just kind of
gone this is dispatch look some so Queen
g2 b5 was the wrong move to plate
because of ether well this is security
sacrifice yeah it's tactically not
working yeah it takes up six movies is
really nice so just what would happen if
if black took the Queen and then Bishop
g2 yeah and then you're also attacking
durog so it's three piece against like
for the Queen
so yeah it's some dangerous stuff so
Josh chose to recapture 106 and then
after f3 what's going on here he's a
piece down any compensation any like a
five and B for ideas or maybe just be
four and then something like Knight d5
um he displayed these to be 495 but I
don't really think that's going to be
near and the compensation she's just
simply a piece down P piece to upon but
yes so he does have these Center pawns
of something like e 5 if I was both new
game I saw I'm not just reading notation
know these moves make sense in the end
rooks e8 - josh is playing very
naturally I think he is and his I'm very
proud to Josh's even though he is a
piece done he's still keeping his cool
and trying to make the best out of his
position a lot of players would just
lose it after they lose a piece so Rick
see one was White's choice and this
makes me wonder what happens if we
attack this night on v3 where's it going
to go back to a 1 yeah a 5 roof scene
when I was playing the game so so you're
saying at a 5 now yeah I like to say 5
move asking a lot of questions about
this night and then if I am allowed to
play a move like a 4 and a 3
then there's going to be some serious
dark-squared weaknesses for white
especially with this bishop on g7 yeah
it's um it's it's really interesting to
see that's I really like around
somewhere around here I thought that the
figures Joe had us and we were done
but here it looks like we still have
room to breathe I'm actually you mean do
you see 26 strikes means a little bit
odd I'm not sure I understand the idea
this doesn't seem like the time to
improve your queen slightly by bringing
it to d6 it seems like the time to
launch the attack yeah I agree with 85
very poor yeah
I honestly I'm not sure if there's any
other ideas here maybe a five who's
worrying about Bishop b5 defending some
white squares what Queen these things
does not help yeah no I'm not I don't
understand Queen d6 but maybe that's one
reason why a five isn't it
I am not sure what's exactly people the
players are hoping here well this is
this is really hard for me to understand
because yeah since black has lost that
piece he should have Oh actually fear is
also I don't understand so what if h5
now I just blocked this side and see
that that makes sense to me I mean as
for you I would just kind of I would
want to be comfortable in my piece up
position somehow and find some way to
maybe simplify things so maybe that's
what g5 is aiming for so g5 is pretty
much just trying to block the Queen
sticking side so he can keep both of
them can keep their focus on their Queen
side um you know that doesn't sound like
it should be right but possibly that's
right like it's up to ya d4 is not a
move I like to see this really stunts
the bishop on g7 and gives white this a
four square yeah also the bishop on f1
now could be a real monster yeah I don't
yeah I don't like the way this
was going when he actually captures on
g5 yeah I don't know III don't like this
for Josh 2000 he's got it
awesome thanks Leslie he seems like he's
got a dress he's got it or otherwise I
don't understand chest
where are the tactics are the tactics
after E 5 were the tactics after f5 or
it doesn't matter you can play whatever
you want I want to say whatever but one
important thing is that Knight takes c3
actually is a huge threat here you can
take back with the Queen and then
there's no c4 because the bishop isn't
defined yeah yeah that is that it's
correct so II five of us played on the
board and um
kingi aides I would really love to have
my queen on like etho right now but
that's might be illegal move it this
point yes so Ashley just just powers
through with f5 immediately was he going
to go through with f6 or ecigs
honestly you might just go through with
Bishop takes h6
I think this is the hidden meaning here
so maybe black has to capture on e3
first I agree what is it sweet guy just
queen e3 and then Queen g3 event it's
just it's devastating this just looks
like checkmate to me yeah
Lissa's got it I was thinking like a
bobbies game so Fabi still has this
extra space he has some nice control
over this diagonal with the battery on B
3 and C 4 Mike's probably looking to
place something like Bishop e6 here and
just trade off some of these nasty
pieces
umm problem for Fabi maybe it's that
after age 6 the dark squared Bishop
doesn't have a lot of options
yeah maybe he could create some options
it's something to have the bishop to do
in this they're not but I feel like
that's too much dreaming
yeah it definitely looks looks difficult
oh yeah if you're just joining the
stream hello hello - DJ chest dog hello
Denise ear who says hello to you I'm not
sure
oh um that's Nick orhan she is she is
she goes to sue she's a graduate student
yeah she's a she's also from Turkey
awesome
well hello hello thanks for joining us
and so Queen D 1 was fabi's option her
fabi's choice I'm not sure
III don't fully understand this move but
I wanna say father's got it but
yesterday I was also sure she got it and
uh yeah that the end game - it's really
well do you understand do you understand
the smooth I I'm not really sure what
the aim is maybe he's just bringing the
Queen tip to e2 for some reason just
well I feel like if maybe we could think
about it like so what is my queen doing
here just putting fish right here but
I'm never gonna actually get anything
out of it so maybe that's why I clean d1
oc6 let's play the game so maybe he has
some ideas with - doing D PI square but
I'm not entirely sure if I don't know
it's it's too deep for me so C C's was
played and Queen eats you so yeah you
were right you wanted to place is going
on e - but to what purpose
I feel like the next few moves are going
to be for white trying to double up his
rooks on the deef D file and I still
don't have to play through this maybe he
wants responsibly Bishop e3 and exchange
just bishop since he can't really make
anything that's happened with it so I'm
actually kind of expecting you Bishop d3
here I thought father would want to keep
these pieces on yeah especially because
when the bishop is an e6 the bishop
doesn't really have anywhere to go and
the night on d8 like night though knight
should be on e6 but and I was gonna say
with this Queen I need to maybe five
he's looking to play c4 and b5 and this
is why he got it
this man I'm thinking if he has his
bishop on a tree then this may be c4 c5
but oh wow yeah I want to be five
actually I'm thinking if he does if he
gets to play c4 and let's say C 5 then
this bishop looks like it's just a
gigantic bomb so I can just play Bishop
b2 and have put my pressure on e how
interesting yeah I was looking to play
b5 because I wanted to put this Bishop
on a3 but b2 is actually a very nice
square for it after c4 I like father's
position it's quite annoying for black
so trying to find moves here find ideas
because first of all where do you put
your knight
if you touched your Bishop where do you
take it do you take it back 57 you have
to admit that there should be six didn't
really makes much sense so this is
definitely difficult
I thought fabi's ideas are pretty clear
to play in c4 see if I were c4 b5 he has
this like he is that's black blacks
ideas for the better horses right yes I
think fog is playing well yeah I feel
like our first two boards got it not to
mention he's up like six minutes which
is let's take a quick look at Nikolas we
haven't seen in a while so I think this
is a definite chance for us to take a
lead in the match area oh is this match
up with Nikolas and some girl so Nikolas
is in typical style because has ripped
open the the Kings side and he's looking
to attack the White King yeah see it's
something we've come to expect we came
from school together and I made the
comments that's he's going to go fool
g4g flash for us well I didn't feel
immediately no I
it seems to be the way he plays in his
pro wrestling matches yeah tends to do
well we left those around here players
trying to open up the board and it looks
like they managed apparently I
personally like these positions
especially as black if I'm playing a
lower rated if I'm playing a higher rate
that I feel like they'll know how to to
don't know better than me how to defend
but also
yeah I've never really liked these
positions for light with the bishop on
g2 yeah I just felt like it didn't make
much sense though again these kind of
positions make a lot of sense to be
played in fast chess because if its
standard gain you can't spend 20 minutes
and try to completely understand what
are you doing what you don't want to do
and yeah but Bishop f3 was played Bishop
f6 so when he calls just improved his
bishop pushed for F sacrifice the F
butts got the edge
yes sir am I missing something here I
think I would like to just play Bishop
g4 here I'm not sure why that move
wasn't good it really just cement the
white squares why I like your idea I
like it more than rooks to you because I
feel like Russia I'm giving them a MIDI
event something slower like Rick f6 just
preparing yeah yeah I really hate this
nice here though I wish I could do
something you would it yeah that's
that's a valid point it's also kind of
funny because in my lectures I've been
trying to teach you know like chess
mm-hmm yeah I think rook she is just
kind of a cheap threat oh yeah I start
New York g3 with checkmate but Bishop
every defense against the threat and it
also brings in some more support for the
game yep
Brooke she does not unknowing move for
those of you who attended my lectures
um but Bishop f3 and now is looks like
why this whole thing perfectly um I want
to see how they're trying I want to see
how Nikolas is trying to so black would
love to play Bishop h3 but there's this
annoying Knight f4 moon yes for the
moment somebody's trying to solve this
problem by bringing a knight to d3
but what if not if Kim can I actually
play that a for now uh yeah I think that
that's totally reasonable
maybe I'll I'll play Queen g5 and
my idea now is kind of switched to H 5
and H 4 yeah before we forget if we
thought that fear was just game was very
clear last time we left it and it looks
even more clear now yeah with the
Queen's off the board white is simply
just down a piece and he did play this
a5 idea that we were talking about but a
few moves later then
it's it's easy helpful are too slow now
this taking on g5 was another
interesting I feel like Josh just felt
really pressured at that point and them
yeah this is this is yeah this this
looks rather unfortunate and yeah
there's on the towel
can't blame him for that ok ok let's
take a quick look okay
Wow what's this really got it yeah I
mean he just had a very nice position
and now he has more rooks it looks like
so Oh beautiful sacrifice here Oh 97 Wow
and and yeah it's just over all right
yeah it's like whatever there's
something doing I woke up yeah cool Oh
even I guess Bishop up to is more
accurate than think we have to cuz I'm
like that's a tree or 92 uh well
actually no I'm sorry
so queen up to is more accurate again
because of 92 yeah okay and then you
simply play a king e1 and black is
running out of threats yes that is
completely true no this is suing alright
let's take a quick look at Bubba's game
I thought for once so okay we left it
off somewhere you should this Oh
so what black did go through with yes so
you managed to kind of reroute these
pieces a little bit to get this night
somewhat into the game cg threes
anticipating 96 keeping an eye on that
f4 square yeah um I don't know how it's
still kind of hoping for something like
this should be 2 and C 4 yeah I feel
like the d4 square would be too weak and
that's why it wasn't played on the game
it's a reasonable concern so how it's
probably going to progress with that in
mind
oh it looks like maybe he's considering
some f4 moves just that's what I think
too but um I'm trying to understand what
the nice be better on II want to go
trying to go to see f3 or maybe two g2
she's maybe trying to come to e3 in 30
years but um she plays Bishop c4 first
so it's kind of this awkward thing where
black wants both the bishop and the
night on Easter yeah this is really have
both so yeah it's like you put your
knight on c6 I'm gonna have my bishop on
c4 and that's going to be very annoying
for you ah this ship c8 when's the right
moment to play f4 is this it is this the
moment I still I'm still trying to
understand can I actually clean that d3
first and then Flash Player for now yeah
I think I like 93 um yeah I'm not sure
if g2 is a better square or not then do
you 3 but oh yes I
but um I think you're right that the
night shouldn't stay enough on e 1
rather I feel this a very very nice
positional game that's I'm just going to
use and saw the lectures later yeah
it'll be quite interesting yeah this is
um this is really interesting to just
see how it's like I I wish I'd remember
at the gate I Anu did that games name in
English but it's like all of your pieces
are like so together and then you have
to move one to create squares oh right
yeah I know what you're talking about
yeah no I
yeah but that's so kingi to must play
just I feel like kids is preparing for
an attack on the kingside then he has so
much more time so I I'm very confident
about this games
Bobby's got it's my vision I was wearing
this shirts of go fabi's know it would
be a relevant day to wear it I think the
nice thing about fabi's position is you
can kind of make these like tiny
improving moves as long as he wants
because black's pieces really aren't
going to be doing anything in the main
in the meantime I don't think black has
has any plans of expanding on the Kings
side or the Queen side I agree this is
I'm Brett pretty confident let's keep an
eye on the coolest games yeah this Aston
has to be the keyboard - oh so he does
get this night - d3
what kind of someone was expecting
what is going on so there's this pin on
the knight on f4 yes maybe Bishop ephors
we mess it up around here why it's a
metaphor yeah [ __ ] Queen g5 a3 a3 I
think was a mistake
right yes pushing the 93 horses black to
do what he wants but 93 what if I would
get pinned on the diagonal towards my
king queen see - yeah that was actually
played in the game so this Bishop f5
seems reasonable domain oh yeah oh yeah
this I don't know I think this is gonna
call this game cuz if he does win this
game we yeah that's huge for the match
that is that could be the decisive game
yeah I don't Bishop a5 and what can wait
do I'm going to take on f4 next turn
oh my goodness other idea but what is
wrong with this - the five is they I
don't I don't know what am I missing
okay you have to take on it for if you
don't take on i-4 you're just a piece
down so take on a for take on G - yeah
is king h1 forced what happens on King
f1 maybe King F on I can't have two H
three king up when I was actually
expecting Rick takes f2 huh and then
Queen f2 night f2 king of - Rick f8 oh
yeah that that's what do - well actually
oh no that doesn't quite work because
there's a Ricky 7-minute yeah I was
expecting like King g3 and then 93 but
there's Ricky 7 there which is quite
awkward so yeah King f1 maybe maybe
Bishop h3 was suppose the problem may be
so king h1 played maybe we'll see a
Bishop g4 here that looks like an
interesting way kingi - then Bishop d1
check and I pick up the Queen and I
think I have like one extra piece
somehow or something yeah it's all good
- nice Farouk
but I'm trying to understand so if I
would really like to be able to like
give it a check on the H file right now
but I don't know there's this Bishop H -
always
defend against their what about
something like be sure the [ __ ] yeah
thanks
oh yeah and no night up to is uh they're
playing so quickly
why would there's white with those who
explain so quickly what is going on he
just pre moved and like the most
critical position I've ever seen he just
keep removed what am I missing
how do we win this Bishop g4 I think is
that's just winning yeah I agree then
you tried to put super so on up Street
so bizarre the five was the bad move
right so okay Bishop a5 Ricky seven why
not King h8 oh there's there's Queen c3
yeah yeah Wow so maybe you have to play
Bishop g4 it yeah well what if Ricky
seven check again after Bishop c4 where
do you go
that's an excellent question yeah Bishop
g4 can I just play too right now yeah
maybe that was the way sometimes simpler
is better but still this Ricky seven
idea it's quite dangerous maybe actually
the best move is is rook to g7 and just
say hello hold on
and everybody slow down then a 41 now
there's Bishop g4 yeah maybe
well kind of an absurd defense from
white here having this results Leslie so
one so so guys is one one but this came
really said there are social stuff from
wait yeah this is so what's our current
position
you saw Bishop by five
and white lost black losses attack it's
just to peace to a queen Wow crazy
I guess the attacks not totally dead
what if I play h5 here hmm
is anything happening oh wow it looks
more interesting but let's keep in mind
that both of the players or have just
yeah down to the final yes if Black
Angus Knight to f3 could create more
chances but I don't know if those
chances are going to be enough to
actually be dangerous you know I mean
okay let's say what if as white I just
play Queen e2 right now so just try to
defend my white scores yeah yeah hello
Nikolas still still has some threats in
this position it's not totally dead yeah
I agreed you know quickly check up on
fog it looks like his his phone in stone
said seconds so Fabi did go for some
kind of a Kings side push yeah so wow so
those bishops ended up so a lot of
pieces got traded we saw Knight g5 g5
look what we got the knight on d3 and
got this now I don't see horse so I
guess I mean question is if this line is
better than the bishop which I kind of
think it is I'd see if it was a very
nice square it really pokes at some
weaknesses yeah so alright g4 um seems
reasonable I think yeah he's just going
for this attack well the bishops kind of
out of play she still has three minutes
to figure out how to continue while his
opponents down five seconds ten seconds
is is not enough time to figure out a
position like this yeah also on Nico has
his game
this I honestly feel like Bubba's game
is so if this was like a standard game
he wouldn't he would probably see some
moves differently
it is nice I'm just forcing up in the
age file and bringing this night back to
g4 well what after are you gonna play
wicked strong clean history I think Rick
h1 is nice
I'm threatening to take on d8 and then
play Queen h3 yeah that's so he just
takes some d8 immediately it seems
reasonable as well and I think still
Rick h1 in Africa channel I'll probably
capture that and then play this this
greenish creature to our g8 can't be
right
mas flip yeah just misleading so I think
he intended her KJ go Queen point yeah
do I have time to just play f3 and
defend my stuff I just want to defend my
knight
this looks so only g5 yeah this is this
SP should be winning it's very good I'll
be still playing quickly keeping up the
pressure imagine just Rick h8 checkers
yeah - yep 796 rays yes
King e6 I guess the line continues but
um just queen g4 you just cook cube
checking him yeah I don't know Queen
Queen g4 King d6
I like that fabi's pausing here using
his time because it does feel like
wreckage shader or something has to be
winning in this position I agree but but
what is it sir okay Jay King of 7-9 age
1606 yet queen g4 king d6 yes then how
do you continue I guess we're about to
find out thank you thank you Asia okay
oh wait
Queen b3 maybe it difficult position
it's Queen back to g4 oh wow cream back
to do you want to know the dollar is
just going to be checkmate well there's
King s6 and then somehow maybe night g8
is finally enough to win the game it
should be I mean come on
yeah so Queen d5 and something like 98
or maybe there's there's even better ah
this looks so stress for me no I I think
this game's over
keep the chicken the chicken he's got
time he's got time I respect I respect
the patient's thank you know I would
just plain he8 and let black off with
this exchange sacrifice what actually
picking g5 is that a it doesn't know
sorry I'm sorry um so if nature for me
became g5 this is not my only concern is
what what's happening there cuz I'd be
tempted to go for that and not let black
off quite so easy but so you gots got a
98 so I was just going for them more
material and the weak King and yeah I'm
in your cage seven next and this is this
is dead this does not make that known
what it
oh wow so the big result actually
Nicholas's game we see a draw there yes
oh yeah Nicholas somehow save that
position so this is huge
why it's gonna be so mad yeah this is
this is amazing so did they they repeat
it here interesting they repeated in
this position where I think why it's
just simply winning well special thanks
to Sandro Mariko maybe Morita I don't
know I actually have some Argentinian
friends that I remember from 7:13 so Oh
Bobby's game is over everyone yet Hey
alright so well done to the team so this
actually puts us ahead in the match by a
half point Mike's gonna be so happy yeah
actually I guess by uh by one point by
one game I'm it's always we're doing
those that that matthan and teammates
but also the thing is um at the end of
the game in the last round I believe
that josh is playing against a 1900 so
yeah very relevant and I think we have
the one and only Mike comer as well as
Mike here to introduce the Grandmaster
vara Cobian the guy that got us into the
floor
and yessir as well maybe we'll take just
a quick break while we get them into the
chairs here to talk about okay thanks
guys what a what an exciting day of
chess now take a look I have something
really interesting I want to show you
seems pretty innocuous right but
actually whites threatening to play e5
it's okay blacks no slouch he sees the
threat and counters it by playing he
fight himself yet white is relentless
attacking e5 with the knight black
defense with his knight in stronger
games but in this game
d6 was played to which the amazing
response d4 was played how can black
even want to continue here maybe Bishop
g4 but black says no no or White's
essence huh no ah white says that's a
dumb idea Bishop g4 is so stupid and I
will show you the line but I know all
our viewers at home can see it calculate
it easily without me having to move the
pieces that after de Queen da King D 895
wins the pawn black sees this refuses to
fall for White's tricks
and white says I'm gonna check meet you
buddy black says no I like to develop
and stop checkmates white says I'm gonna
redouble the attack on f7 with Queen b3
looks like black some quite a pickle
here wouldn't you say Queen d7 won't do
it so he plays Queen e7 threatening to
play Queen b4 check if BB 7 comes on the
board trading off the Queen's and taking
the steam out of whites attack white of
course just plays normal chess starts
developing black plays c6 to keep that
night off the d5 and b5 the golden rules
are being followed folks this is
exciting stuff this is exciting stuff
which side will White Castle on nobody
knows black thinks that Bishop is really
annoying so he tries to get rid of it
but does white have a surprise for him
as Jonathan sharks like to say Wow I'll
take those pawns and get a winning
unstoppable attack what do you have to
say about that black pieces not King d8
because castles long leads into a quick
forest win for white
and the rest just explains itself
doesn't it folks I'm attacking your PIN
piece you have to defend it and my
position so strong and so few of your
pieces are in play that I can just
sacrifice all my stuff just throw it
away and check meet you but what if you
try and trade off my strongest attacking
piece will I fall for it and take here
no sir no I will not
back to you guys in the studio hi again
welcome back I'm door so they're
actually I have GM war here
hi everybody so we're both on the
assemblers Archbishop's and bar helped a
lot with the team to get here and we
wanted to ask you so what are your
predictions how do you like the team and
the team is very strong I played that
early on in the summer league and I
helped the team qualify to this stage
and now we have both Leslie and Fabiano
available so dream lineup so it's so
looking really good so far so I hope you
know this it's fine not natural
oh well as well so we'll win this and be
the champions for the summers and thank
you so yeah we have two more matches to
go through and the so far of you one
point up and I hopefully will manage to
keep that up from what I heard from my
just a few seconds ago we have five
updates following matches that of your
favorites looks promising but so yeah
okay we're playing I think so but yeah
that's going to be hopefully we're not
going to get there yeah so it's going to
be very interesting don't you think
do you have just a game of day playing
right now yeah yeah they started a few
seconds ago this game so this is
Nicholas's game against their board for
and it's going to it looks like it's do
you want to look at from okay yeah we
can go quickly so Nicolas block yeah
yeah he's very good very good play very
dangerous
well ninety seven and this is clever so
if you take the pot 95 he wants to play
see six yeah attacking the bishop and
then attacking the bishop and then if
the bishop moves you have this Queen a5
check
winning it's night it's interesting yes
it's a clever idea 97 something like
this Nicholas is very tricky in an
Orthodox Claire so lot of people you
know maybe don't know how but he play
really well for the fraud chess make
yeah and help us mike has a lot of faith
in him you need a prediction yesterday
that's he Nikolas will play in st. [ __ ]
up and sometimes soon close futures in
five years but yeah I would like to see
that yes very tricky
yeah actually played Nikolas so let's
see here so he's so he's obviously
feeling to win this game so this is a
big game I feel also while I was trying
to be able to play tricky he's also
trying to oh no I am so sorry for the
technical difficulties that's we are
experiencing right now and I don't know
what to do yeah
and then I have to follow the players
again so yeah I also knew closest
birthday is coming up it's he's going to
be 19 to September this is the Wesley
game right yeah this is Wesley's game
I'm trying to follow the players so so
yeah what is your prediction in this for
this is the next two rounds so the score
is we have what in half or in half to
three and I think so yes cuz you're only
one points ahead so let's see yeah this
is the important game this is Wesley
playing white against their board one
yes
Claire very strong grandmaster so looks
like Wesley is doing well it's got a
nice space advantage there on the in
center and now he's trying to push me on
the kingside maybe you'll consider
pushing h4 h4 h5 put some more pressure
maybe we'll put up on h6 just to to
annoy but very direct so when i boys
sicilian against this structure it
always kind of worries me to play
something like if five because of the e5
square but i guess that's something we
have to work on later
well the thing is yeah the point of f5
is if you let's say you play etext f5 it
takes at five at some point the light
square bishop will come off the board
and then you have this excellent outpost
for tonight to go to old defense so you
will just play 95 so that's why he's if
the f4 does not take let's see if I just
play 95 immediately then could you think
about you can consider even f6 I'm not
sure he will do that right away but it's
definitely something he will consider
maybe he will play first b3 just to
protect the c4 pawn because you don't
wanna drop the c-4 pulse it will just
play b3 and then you can continue you
know we should before put more pressure
all right so you're pretty optimistic
about this yeah I mean this is this is
still unclear it's not so clear but you
know but I like I like yeah you know the
position so let's take a look at maybe
fabi's game this is a my said I wanted
to see from the barrage are playing for
it it's just image like from Brazil
right oh yes very very dangerous place
yes definitely someone to watch out for
yes so spring Fabi and now he's probably
sacrifice the pawn they started very
I didn't I wasn't expecting this okay
Scandinavian yeah okay there was some
repetition right isn't one of the big
lines here trying to play 95 yeah it's
possible you can play like 95 Bishop
before yeah yeah that's why we decided
to play Knight to e4 b transpose opening
excellent six and Bishop c4 interesting
so what's what's not going to try and
play long cast was he because so here he
can try maybe to play it let's say if
you play Bishop c3 it's just gonna be
passive bishops it's been here we'll
play long Council and the block is
putting a lot of pressure so he decided
to actually just sacrifice a pawn Castle
in White has also lead leading
development now f6 bonus under attack so
I feel like the main question is how is
black trying to make everything happen
with bishops obesity 7 makes well now he
might want to call alone Castle actually
yeah that's what I was just thinking
about so we don't move such a strict e1
makes sense
oh yeah book t1 is definitely a
possibility actually in the game they
played Bishop d3 take take and clean c6
yeah I'm not sure if I like this as much
because it feels like now it's not so
much anymore so that's clear yeah
hopefully Fabi has some compensation
here but it seems like now rook GA talk
g6 block is just up
rook g8 now threatening raids on g2
that's probably gonna force a move like
f3 and then h7 is hanging so block will
put the rookin g6 and I feel like wax
game blacks position is just simpler to
place especially since it's gone up and
well can also play rook d h5 he chose to
play more aggressively then you know I
was just thinking just get the rookin
but he now is trying to be he sees he's
confident that he is absolutely fine
so he's even taking more aggressive now
ideas like H 5 H 4 maybe even Rock age 6
so how's Bobby proceed it's tricky
because it's not so much material left
on the board early nights
ok so perhaps maybe this h5 was over
optimistic little bit because now Queen
g7 is quite annoying yeah feels like it
was a little premature yeah Lukey Luke
g6 looks really good that's my original
idea now the problem is that say if you
go to page six now he plays Bishop f8
and we should be four so who's winning
actually about like how should black
maybe maybe could heap maybe yeah yeah
what's laughing it beats this is a place
to try to look out for fatigue like
Queen a for some ideas
yeah this game just got a whole lot yes
this H hh5 idea will spit rushed in a
little bit so yeah there is feel like
it's white has a compensation
yeah well this this match was definitely
the man D game of this round to look for
especially since oh we already have a
result draw interesting can we see what
happened why draw yeah we left up
somewhere around here yeah yeah no if I
was played already
so f 596 B 3 big take so blackout is
breakthrough quits
there's a very defined O'Keefe ISO
so definitely White's position is little
bit loose now with the king
yeah especially because I would want to
play something like win g2 but I can't
because of my fishermen III is hanging
so rookie five fish over four or five so
that's probably that's how they ended up
repeating they repeat it is right yeah
well this this kind of looks logical
because I don't so how if he didn't want
to repeat the say after five how would
you proceed well the problem is d5 pawn
is hanging yeah so you might have to
start thinking about something like
Queen g2 as I was kind of thinking about
but after Queen G 2 downloads would you
just define event and then also some
Bishop g7 yeah I mean firstly they don't
like this because Bishop g7 bishop
before check so I think this was a
logical logical way to just indeed
scheme and so I feel like our our match
hangs on this came here these two games
Nikolas games and Josh's games and
Nikolas already looks well what what
he's opponent just gave the Queen that's
strange
oh wow well I guess it was losing
already there was no there was no good
way to defend against Mishra - but the
bishop is looks horrible in situ I mean
the Knights position which is terrible
yeah this will be a win so that's gonna
make it - so so the score is 5 for now
right yeah no if this is a will be 6-4
yeah yes but this game worries me quite
a lot actually
you think far beyond any trouble little
bit mm um I would be very happy if this
game ends in a draw
oh yeah yeah a draw would be a good
result because you know there's a two
part two pointed out that unity yes also
the game for Josh we haven't gotten a
chance to look at gosh yes yes so he's
underdog in this game and he's playing
against creeks horse yeah okay josh is
doing great though he's like a pawn yeah
he's solid yeah he shouldn't lose this
she had the first two games pretty rough
but this game he's absolutely fine
actually I just need to and you know
look beat
just put the look on look tqp Josh seems
to play very logical chess
so I have high hopes on for this game
not to so the good news is Josh does
make something out of this game draw or
then the next game she's playing their
board for and she has the upper hand
yeah this should be good I mean as long
as he just manages his clock
he shouldn't lose this game so he can
only win or draw here so okay the eight
is coming you know so a pair of the
rocks I mean
yeah this pawn yeah if white starts
taking this fun and there's yourself too
I'm gonna drop the beat reform yeah a
pond might still be remaining since two
might give some winning chances for you
though yes so you played the purchase
league do you for our specific yeah so
what was your favorite game
oh my favorite water remember I didn't
get to play down much this year because
with the way our lineup was that we
could actually have what Fabiano and
much but even last year just oral
purchase leaky I have a favourite that's
well my very favorite game is its from
2017 it was the final match we were
playing against Norway grants so Magnus
was playing there and I I won my last
game and clinched the title for a for
our team so it was a Ben Oni game and I
beat grandmaster lee Jaden Lee and I had
a nice exchange sacrifice and it was the
last match so once I beat him we already
clinched you know like even though like
our players could lose all the games but
we already clinched it so so that's the
most memorable game because I gave us
the protesting title yeah that sounds
really great we're really glad to have
you here today and thank you very much
yeah and yeah it's always fun and I'm
you know and it's you know watch you
know with Mike at the club to see if we
can clinch it you know so it's very good
so far yeah fun to watch to win and
watch Mike side absolutely okay great
thanks hey thanks guys this is some
exciting chess Wow
I am just a happy camper all this chess
I don't know what to do I am beside
myself anyway I want to talk to you guys
about a very interesting position take a
look at this what a doozy oh my goodness
how does white proceed here is he
winning is he losing drawing nobody
knows unless he finds the amazing move
rook to whatever square that is
now the casual observer may say didn't
you just hang your rook on h6 and I'll
tell him take it
and then I'll say checkmate back to you
guys in the studio
huge thanks to var for doing that a
special interview for us giving us
giving us his thoughts on these games
and I don't want to waste any more time
the games are all underway so let's just
get back to the analysis so yeah then
this position as we were just talking
with war Josh actually has so we left it
off somewhere and a little around here
liftin yeah Josh this player work t2 and
josh is just trying to make leap logical
legal moves and just to see how it's
like George was asking these opponents
so what do you want to do it's not like
we have much options so it's interesting
especially since he's officially one
pawn up on the board and this nine done
before is pretty annoying for white to
watch out yeah definitely an awkward
position for White House the Fabiana
game day oh yeah one that really caught
my eye
[Music]
alright so we were somewhere around here
yeah when we left off Fitz King f8 g 3
was plays
interesting so black does get control
over this D file but I don't know this
this is a very strange position in my
opinion on things like Bishop h6 are
possible but then it's the construction
of blacks pawns really control every
square in the G file so it's desert for
what to continue an attack in any
meaningful way it doesn't feel like
Bobby has um that pleasant position I
wish I was gonna say in a composition
but I changed my mind a second but um
maybe if I was planning great xt5 than
just bishops III Oh actually see your XE
thing
yeah because if the this rook on d3 is
like one of the few pieces left on the
board right it's like he's your column D
tree is much more active and in the game
than the row kind of fun so make sense
to want to keep this route but then now
it mean it means that Fabi lost the
control over this D files my concern so
we see Queen d7 and I I don't see how
Fabi really activates this pieces here
Bishop f4 is possible but you might run
into
maybe this 'if eyes move could just shut
that down yeah he goes for Bishop e3 I'd
be tempted just to play Rick do you want
for for black and started some sub
counter-attacks on the first rank so
yeah and that's very optimistic about
this game to be honest yeah it
definitely looks tough Wow let's let's
take a look that's Nikolas this game
does he eat so he still has more Queens
I still like his position was it Queen
to two nights
he should be able to make this happen
yeah simply d5 next I think is this plan
and that'll be yeah yeah but that that
looks quite good yeah this make all the
students have any troubles winning this
game um so really it's just down to Josh
yes Bobby I think I definitely trust
Josh to be able to love the situation to
trust Josh morning so modern Bobby yeah
I think so I think well not not to win
but but to get a draw here I don't know
I'm still hopeful that Bobby could pull
her out of his hat yeah definitely
but in this case I mean Josh just says
such a solid position he's up upon that
I think like even might start seeing
from Joshua
yeah like Rick's to 7 and then 93 d7
maybe why would you play with d7 there's
my part attacks but oh wait actually
easiest night before could be tricky to
play it well actually could you night
the night before just repeat ooh but I
can definitely image
oh wait night before 93 I'm sorry
thinking and what if ecigs yeah up so
dirty so much repetition repetition
that's what I'm looking for I'm a little
worried if something like each race
played on might can't get out that kind
of worries me um more than I would like
to but even if eg
yeah I had that sort of singing d4 d5 um
then I can just take on e3 and the 9th
nd trees hanging so yeah maybe weights
weight might try something like you you
384 and then II for a chance yeah but in
that case even stuff like 93 checkmate
might become playable maybe but we are
hoping the Josh within something listen
yeah yeah Sadie 44 his plate and then
how can we extract this night what about
just a 5 a 5 might be for just
reasonable yeah it's very reasonable I
wanted to say hello to chess Wiebe
who is in the chatroom oh I believe it's
Dennis Boros or alien is Nick what are
the two usually it's Dennis I think
either one no you both hello
Josh's plays Rick c7 so now I'm 93 might
not be a threat but rook c3 however
might be I don't know I still feel like
if it works maybe a five and the night
before might be safer way to go yeah but
now you've kind of pinned yourself for
that plan
what 67 yeah I still think it's well in
hand for Josh I like this Rick c3 idea
and then I mean how does white continue
if you move tonight then all of a sudden
d3 becomes very come I do something like
65 now rook d5 rook c3 you take my pawn
I guess mm-hmm interesting what's going
on there I guess I could play rook takes
b3 in that case yeah
dad actually that's kind of simple
enough yeah I think josh has this under
control okay
see how is Nicola do whoa this is not
that I expected a lot hahaha seems good
enough to me
yeah he is so we just won the game so
all right so that's just that's another
huge win so let's just hope Bobby
doesn't um mm-hmm lose this game even
though if Bobby's in trouble if you were
to lose this game we still just have to
go to two in the final round in order to
this ah to win the match that is true
actually um as long as Josh would draw
his game yeah at least I'm just worried
because of Josh when he gets some time
pressure it's um yeah hi before whoa
90s ringy yeah 93 checkmate my Tiki tree
let's just check me let's just check me
please mr. e please point out history 93
ah that's it alright alright there's
gonna be so happy 93 you'll see plays so
this puts us at to seven points
so total oh yeah so that means we just
need one one and a half more in the last
all rights official Josh phone all right
best so to Henry W be who asked those
night before when the Black Knight no
because he checkmate yeah so of course
if white were to capture this night or
take c1 is checkmate
and if why we're not is no matter what
checkmate no lines yeah alright so Fabi
actually if even papi
worst-case scenario he does lose this
game we still are - yeah are we through
our wait so if Bobby loses this game we
just need one and a half points in the
final around oh yeah watch the match so
things are looking very very good for us
here come on and that's a big if as far
as Fabia losing this game yeah but I
definitely think it's far from over
of course of course the bank the big
question is how can black try to make
progress and well he's got a lot of
pressure on this d3 pawn yeah I would
like to see if anybody in the chats with
like to give us some ideas about this
game because this is the game that we're
gonna be looking for in the next as long
as it finishes so feel free to give us
ideas comments if you're - missions or
it we're happy to talk about it one
thing to notice this Fabi is a little
bit of time here
not that fridges at all uncomfortable
uh-huh and load time control standards
but it is a relevant factor so we see
Queen f3 these flight scores are a bit
weak for for white but I'm not sure
maybe I should try something like f5
with the idea of playing age for an h3
grace I I agree with that but um is
there any way that black can could be
anywhere better gonna eh it's just yeah
I'm not sure it's tough to find shelter
I kind of liked its home on f8 actually
compared
yeah for the moment there is a problem
for black on c5 that ponies attacked
twice so maybe we have to defend this
how would you play b6 I really don't
want to but I think I would I don't ha
giving up this pawn I don't fully agree
with this decision
I think these six was a bit more solid
for Fabi I mean what else besides
besides taking this pawn here I guess
you do have to be a bit careful
Oh Bobby took us he does take but I mean
what I why not Bishop takes Bishop and
then and then Age 4 oh I guess no the
Queen so they exchange it the bishops on
c5 so probably got his pawn back yeah
well I was concerned about age for h3
still but with the Bishop gone yeah also
with the donate for ya yeah with the
bishop on e7 that's that's why you
couldn't couldn't take earlier but no
the bishops have been traded how many
more rounds
one more round after this one and with
the way things are going it's looking
like will only need to score one point
in that final round to clinch the match
oh wait can I just
yeah I would play queen bee for you yeah
I'm digging maybe can I actually play c8
first rook c8 oh that is a nasty idea so
he just goes for Queen before me
kneeling but Rick see at first actually
looks it's very very dangerous
yeah
so one interesting thing if Bobby
actually wins this game something
already then we we would have eight
points total we just need a half point
to win the game to win the match in the
final round and with Bobby and Wesley on
the team it's hard to imagine we don't
score in there it's very difficult to go
for four to zero against this lineup so
it looks like it's gonna be repetition
yeah which is it's a good match strategy
this this half point means a lot going
into the final round
can you still do their work see either
it's lost that's it looks strong to me
still I mean what how do you how do you
meet this threat you play like Queen d5
I guess and try to trade off the Queen's
but then no no it's not so clear there
are things like Queen h8 to look out for
I don't know I feel like just play clean
yeah that's what I'm gonna say just do
the repetition your team is already
winning I think that's the part the the
smart match strategy from yeah but let's
see if he will actually take it or not
will he take the draw
uh why not because he wants to win the
game funny question because I was just
thinking about the team overall instead
of yeah absolutely
yeah there's no business I mean it's not
entire it's not entirely useless to
tackle so he does decline the repetition
especially with the clocks I think it's
reasonable for Robbie to try to land but
so we see Queen d8 and maybe h4 now from
from Fabi to try and create some
problems for this King I don't know I
still want it there a petition though
yeah I I don't know I admire it from
Fabi even if you were to somehow
miraculously lose this game we're still
in a great position going into the final
round because like we're here all the
punches the victory for us well so after
your four I think there is some serious
checkmating threads Queen g8 it is yeah
and no Queen g5 this is why I wanted to
play deep for to stop visit that's good
how is the pawn in the game actually 83
rank I'm thinking is it
well fog he's got a minute to calculate
it let's see if he goes for it
my first instinct is to avoid the pawn
in him because what I think is more
centralized and so now Persia is
actually is straight offering the Queen
trade would you play Queen you change
Queen c7 there's a lot of moves to just
consider so hang on how is the pawn in
game though Queen takes Queen and then I
I agree with you that the king is really
centralized yes not gonna be the best my
fear was just white always just have
this threat of playing f3 and then g4
and then having a name that is true God
so let's just think about it so if the
kick if the Queen's are off the ward in
the King was on d5 would mean that you
have one two three moves to try and take
the pawn on e5 and then he puts
pushing but then f3 it would be one too
it's I don't think it's done risk if you
were yeah if you were going to venture
that's not a bad game no in this case
Queen III I think it's mobsters I
completely agree with you it seems just
winning I would definitely play Queenie
through here and then this protected
past H pawn is white would just be
winning the game yeah if we know our
opponents game yeah and so no no no no
no matter what the black king is always
going to have to be tethered to the the
Kings side ah I'm just relieved to watch
this game and not the same time oh yeah
maybe a four here just to give so we're
distance starts going wrong
he pushed so hard right yeah I think
bringing this King back to the center
and playing things like King King e7 was
just not the right way to do it
uh do I not know my partner's games well
this is why I wanted to play e4 it's
because I was worried black might try
something like e 5 and f4 and then we no
longer have this protected passer scams
man gave me a heart attack
so what's going on it's like playing
King takes g3 here like it's lagging oh
shoot
well I mean yeah great but uh King takes
g3 I think it's the problem and then h5
for queening at the same time well I'm
not gonna complain about that one yeah
it was a very very interesting game it
was really tough to understand who is
doing what yeah going back a few moves I
think instead of King e2 not quite that
king you two in this right here I would
have liked to see e4 after um yeah after
King at 7 I think
efore was a much better way to
neutralize yeah I agree you just offer
up offer straight up so you play e4 if
you take take call there's a king of
seven yes sir before you take I just
take and we just I'm going to turn for
Ag for first wait actually
yeah I don't know it I guess it is
actually a tough and game I'm sitting um
what about g4 o g4 I thought I could
take I'll take back and then King g6e
for I think I even have I don't have
that five there know if you can get six
then I play it fine and then you would
have to go back and I don't know what
I'm doing
yeah I think that that's the only line
for black though but maybe it's enough
maybe it's not enough
maybe g4 is the way opponent games are
deceptively tricky I was always so proud
of my father's games um how's the chat
doing anybody any questions comments
concerns um yeah Henry's wondering why
isn't giving up the G and H file pawns
during this game which if you go forward
actually it's not so clear that that
father's just kidding yeah we aren't
sure exactly how it's going to turn out
if the King were to capture on g3 in
most positions then the white pawn on h4
it would be able to promote in this case
I think King takes g3 is still the right
move because as soon as you start
pushing that H pawn the F pawn is
actually going to come down the board
and both sides will actually be
promoting so that's why I think this
final position here is is the computer
is giving a draw
yeah come out together alright so I know
I think that it'll be some queen versus
queen and those are you know very tough
to win hmm so how are how are things
looking this problem set for us again we
just need to so we need a half point out
of four games in the final round to win
I'd like to have Mike in the studio
kidding me I'm sure he'll come in for
for some perfect Dre speech after this
last round I think is gonna learn his
again oh yeah I think I think he's
always got that thing with them here we
have a question from Nani suam how do
you guys count pawn races do you just
calculate ah do the accounting thing
where you
the way I usually do it is so let's not
hide upon him beat you I'm sure he has a
pun and they'll say g6
and if it's my move I just going so I
have I have 1 2 3 4 5 votes to make a
queen and from g6 he has one two three
four five moves medically and depending
on where Kings are and then it's kind of
got a little complicated because if the
king can if the king is in that that's I
want to say square square yeah then you
have to be able to calculate the Kings
you have to include the Kings so you can
be like so I have one move before then
let's say how am i king on b5 then I
have to move my king to let's say C six
or B or C if I have something usually I
count white boots first so and then I'm
a clay so I have like five months for
white and I have five one for black and
I usually do it like that but I don't
know it's I don't really know if there
is it right way to do it so there's this
kind of shortcut where you just count
the number of moves that you need to
promote in the number of moves your
opponent needs to promote and then just
kind of compare those numbers but I
think it really just depends the
compositions you really just have to
kind of calculate move by move all sites
you have enough time it's a good idea to
do it both ways you think about it with
their moves that you need and your
opponent needs and then you think about
it and then you actually calculate so if
I put me for g5 blah blah blah
yes so going into this final round
Fabiana will be paired against board one
for Sao Paulo which is saundra of Mariko
Wesley so we'll have a difficult task of
taking down Ali Riza for Joe Nicholas
Theodore who will be playing against GM
cry car and then finally Josh will be
playing against Lucas Cardoso on board
for and I think they're all gonna be
interesting games to watch I'm not sure
who do you think is favorite between
Wesley and firoozeh in this time control
I think it's going to be very very
closely yeah it's like something we just
saw here it doesn't really close match
fears Joe had the upper hand
a lot of
I'm gonna say a lot of the first half of
the game for user had the upper hand but
it looked like Bobby didn't even have
compensation but George the towards the
second half of the game Bobby started to
pull stuff out of his head out of a hat
so definitely made me to turn around
since head III guess a winning position
in this King and Ponton game but somehow
but it's really understandable to
miscalculates simple and games no
special actually III really respect them
at my father before pushing so much more
than just the repetition and he we got
some beautiful end games out of it
that's personally using my lectures yeah
and it actually did pay off because
despite a position possibly being John
Frazier I couldn't couldn't pull the
trigger on playing a move like King
takes g3 yeah and just ran out of time I
do want to take on that look at Josh's
game cuz I feel like that's the game too
that's like that's the game that's I
would have my money on really if I was
pretty good for Josh to win um yeah
interesting because josh is a very
logical chess player from what I've seen
in the past few days and what I've heard
throughout the league but so Scotch
thank you is one of my favorite openings
that I've been playing since I was
seventeen hundred's
h4 yeah this is this is a theme these
days yeah and then c4 ownership since
pushing these H pawns forward
I know Ryan's like instead of
Archbishop's with the h4 bishops
so b3 g6 it seems like a very logical
logical scotch to be played
d to fish up to seven hmm ah that's what
like I feel like you know Josh is trying
to figure out because if he takes it and
he has second
yeah you have to deal with Bishop e5
yeah but then you would it was your joke
or it could take on before and play a
three can you just take on before and
take on a six because if you take C d5
why can't they make you well I thank you
for not leaving oh yeah I think you're
right actually so it takes on d5 takes
on e5 because if you take on d5 when you
take on f1 I can just take back with the
king I feel like and if you take on e5
know I can play Queenie to pin this a
little but I don't know then the
complicated tactics so make sense like
that josh is taking something doesn't
feel the bar seems to like this doesn't
feel right for black here I think it
must just be C takes D here taking this
free night and then what am I missing
see you C takes D Bishop e5 we're saying
takes on b4 oh no no that's before and
then yeah yep yep but I'm saying cd5
Bishop f1 yeah so then then King f1
Bishop e5 and Queen e2 that's what your
self yeah seems logical to me but maybe
black tries to castle before the 165
and then rookie aids Quincy tree yeah no
I think you get away with it I think
it's it's just winning so no you Bishop
f1 doesn't work yeah so what will you do
after cd5 I think it must just be Bishop
e5 and then Bishop a6 Bishop Bishop a1
and you get this rook at least for your
troubles but it this it does not look
good
doesn't that look good job I agree any
other does any over chance member cuz I
want to say visitors I'm running out of
English words yeah and you have yours
yes any questions about these games
please please let us know in the
meantime why don't we take a look at
Wesley's game I can't keep on this game
was I'll come right back to it as soon
as Josh makes a move Bobby and Wesley
you're playing you know so here we see
Fabi this is quite the position yeah we
looked at the opening a little bit it
was with c-45 so English opening um 28
is a strange move yeah Bobby's position
looks a little and the other you know
it's it pressures and the other game we
saw Bobby remote from b3 to d1 and now
we're saying from v6 to the 8th
yeah this starts all wonder why he's
putting his queen out here in the first
place
yeah because Kirsten for father well
actually he has five more minutes on the
clock
so that's could be a very interesting to
see but that's at the same time now that
I know we only need half a point
it's and a little too relaxed I just
hope that the players you see that's the
thing if sometimes you tell you let the
players know that you only need half the
points to win this match then they might
not if they start relying on yeah they
might lose that oh we see Mike walking
around the minds of people too we'll
have to get him in here
after their own finishes up so you have
this going on and I wanted to look at
Peter's just game but best Li so typical
opens GA yeah typical moves this a6 p5
idea ah sorry CC for instead of a
caption unti for which I know this is
miss one not what it is not what I was
taught
yeah usually I just always seen C takes
d4 in this in this type of opening ah
Wesley's going for this extra space he
really wants to get that bishop doesn't
he and he got it okay mr. b7 assuming he
really wants that space he is he is
pushing here he's pushing me five
tick-tick-tick
so okay so I think this things have
settled down a little bit for Wesley now
and I actually quite like his position
there's this nice long open diagonal
from an h1 and there's no light squared
bishop for white to challenge it so you
see moves like Queen d5 things like
Bishop d7 and all of a sudden there's a
lot of threats against the white king
yeah I agree this is definitely one of
the interesting positions of this whole
match but I'm a little worried about the
loan yeah it is a little under defended
but I think if you get this nice battery
along the the diagonal the Queen will
defend the pawn and you can just bring
your up to the B file and yeah things
are things are looking nice let's see
how this is going so Bishop III clean
easy alright so we will get Mike in the
studio after this foil around
25 was played often Whitney's change and
this would be a more pleasant to end
game for black definitely with the
bishops and say when you see Bishop e7
in this diet
this battery upon this diagonal is
complete mm-hmm anyone Bishop c6 you got
the battery you want it's and you also
it's like Wesley is going for the for
the Queen exchanges yeah I think he's
really understands the exchange son game
is gonna be pleasant for him and it's
very unlikely that he would end up
losing yeah what's wrong I still think
I'm sorry I have one I am Josh's
position he's oh he took her it's I'm
sorry he he was thinking upon so he took
on d5 excellent Queenie for King d1
interest Oh 24 was being insistent
that's not the one I was thinking about
but it's definitely interesting I'm sure
the problem is it is kind of stacking up
your pieces along the e-file so now
after King do you develop team tv1 is
something to be played because you can't
really play Bishop III or queen d3
because um I would just simply yeah I
could just just if Queen III perhaps an
exchange and take on f1 I take on e5
with the plate so candy one looks like
to move to be played especially if one
was played through cake one and no me to
like really can't open this key file on
it so Josh just a piece up yeah just a
piece up the problem of course would
like it is if this e file were to open
up the grip would come from the e-file
and then the Queen and King are on the
same line and things would go quite
poorly so josh is up a piece he has a
beautiful I felt as if I was kind of
forgot something he's a piece down just
yeah offering the came straight down
apiece doesn't makes just like c3 and
that's yeah this game looks looks dead
so if Josh wins the first game then the
match is pretty much already over yeah I
I mean it is all a we would
we would be the champions if Josh
where's the witness Josh even manages to
draw this piece it shouldn't be that
hard I hope okay so we can call this one
for Josh here I'm just this time that
Mike's boring me a little since Sam he
keeps thinking about is positioned for
too long and I don't know give me six
minutes against everybody in the world
in this position and I think I think I
could get it done um glad to hear that
all right so let's see Bobby what's
breaking in the center with you for I
mean we already know that the last two
rounds would be the toughest matches for
or for our first two boards right so uh
there's no surprise I'm sorry Josh made
a move I want to watch that's because if
this game does end up and a win for Josh
then the match is over so sure whatever
Josh makes a move if it's okay with you
I'd like to come back and see what he
did
yeah so so far they just change to clean
92 Castle Rock Co and c6 josh is playing
it safe again Josh if you go back and
listen I'm very proud of you you make
logical chest
I very much like it it's it's a great
way to play chess so yeah he's been
playing quite well after out this side
yeah overall it's it feels like he just
he just wants to play strategic moves
logical moves instead of going g4 I sure
will he did play it here but you get my
point
yeah doesn't truly once that's crazy
chess and no blood keeps giving us thank
you
please give all the pieces yeah take
through and doesn't know lights up a
full rook
yeah just Fighter III for all I care if
it makes it rotate it makes perfect
sense just play all right yeah but that
too just don't blow there yeah all right
so let's give it a little bit more time
and watch
Nicholas's game oh he seems like he's
also got it yeah this looks quite nice
the black king is devastated I think we
saw so Nicolas actually did get this
efore break-in yeah we're looking for
right so we were somewhere out here and
we were taking lots having a 484 comes
through and there's an opening up I
think what's just better prepared yeah
it's a really good breakthrough so d4
was play its Queen b3 Curtis ah and you
take the piece nice F Series such a nice
small I was kind of thinking about maybe
if I have a 94 but this is a but I think
this is a more logical way to play chess
I'm also kind of really excited right
now so yeah this is really exciting to
watch and just oh we have a results only
one it were the best all right Wesley
jure firoozeh Thank You Wesley for
making our job easier so now no matter
what happens we can lose the other three
games
we still have clinched the shape it is
very unlikely to lose any of these three
games since Josh is already and rook to
what 2 pounds up and Nikolas is also
yeah the black king is it's very very
unsafe
yeah it's City v is nice just opening
the position oh and these are some nice
tactics all right listen
so Bishop takes 85 I guess the problem
is route 65 we nee 5 and then after rook
FA check King g7 you can play group
takes ea and the Queen is still pinned
so lightning-fast tactics from Nikolas
finding this Mike walking outside with a
big smile and Swiss Mike spacing hey
he's ready ready to celebrate
we should start celebrating right now
yeah
alright so Nikolas schemes should be
winning
Josh's game is winning just a matter of
time
yeah a matter of converting up a full
rook it shouldn't be that hard just
start pushing your pawns and
orange heretics to injury off the board
somehow just just got it
so it's Papa's game because we're did to
leave it leave up somewhere out here I
believe very soon thank you six and then
yeah this night h4 idea so he's trying
to get rid of this white light squared
Bishop before this diagonal opens up all
the way so white plate very naturally
with with you takes d5 I think yes
opening up this diagonal and yeah Bishop
b4 makes a lot of sense this Bishop is a
really important piece for a wait so
looking ain't I should see two rooks eh
it feels very natural for father to play
these moves put his Rex on the open
files yeah I feel like it should be fine
the only a concern is this kind of
wayward night on h4 it really needs to
be there so that on Queen d3o where
there's all six Josh balls yeah Josh won
the game oh my goodness
oh I blended another rook ah yes sir
what time is in prison huh that's a good
question yeah I'm I'm trying to ship you
nearer time control or near a time zone
right yeah I know Iran is like nighttime
now cuz let's it's about ten hours ahead
of us after us
it looks like there are a couple hours
ahead of us and II he's not up in the
middle of the night or anything
he's just playing a bad game
unfortunately yeah well yeah this is the
last really interesting game I think
well uh Nokomis is also
what oh yeah still waiting that's just
it
well just yeah because up upon an in the
bishop endgame is gonna be oh well
actually no no no actually this is this
is totally lost because you can never
play we should be so get the check and
now you were gonna take the ship c6 so
this is just dead yeah this games over
as well
seeking out seven I guess it's a try
yeah 37 okay
Everett p7 and you just play c6 I
suppose yeah ah we have another win
alright okay so remember house will be
yeah its first I said that's the match
will be the games will be very closely
it will be like maybe by one point
oops I told you we would crush them yeah
I was a little worried about how he
would crush them but um well Queen D
through some very surprising move why
not why he had some ideas with well I
thought Bishop g6 would actually be
played and then if if black could trade
off this LightSquared bishop he wouldn't
have quite so many problems but you
played 36 instead which I didn't really
understand I feel like maybe um Bobby is
trying to keep the pressure on this pawn
because he might want to have ideas with
checked taking with checks so maybe
that's why he played then she seeks no
it's probably to move again you want to
take with check I really expected Bishop
e6 there but it's more natural I agree
oh wow so he's just bringing this Knight
to f8 and now I guess he's gonna play
take innovations pond singing let's oh
well not that does too
what's going on in our chats someone
says congratulations thank you very much
chancho thank you and then yet rooks III
might be an interesting SEC and Bobby's
game you know where what's move maybe a
few moves ago with with this knight on
c3 and this Bishop on f7 I don't know if
it was ever actually possible but it was
just something to look out for us
sacrificing and then with this check
with either Queen takes or Bishop takes
d5 yeah yeah I like what Bobby did here
he brought us Knight back to a very
natural square and now after 36 this
just looks like a desperate try yeah
there's Queen takes up six here right
and yeah that was played this is this is
over and we crushed them so the match is
completed I mean yeah we're ready for
Mike to join us here I think the final
score is something like eleven and a
half yeah you got the wine
[Music]
we are in official so so I get this look
at all the hardware we've collected not
two-time world chess champion
international master doors it's a nice
title very nice title unfortunately you
will not be getting any of the bonus the
bonus is going directly into my name I'm
gonna get a nice gold bracelet so you
come to the Chess Club next week you're
gonna see me rocking it oh yeah as long
as you say Archbishop yeah this is that
what you expected to see this crushing
or a crusher crusher crusher we crush
everything you know it's like the
inaugural championship let's not talk
too much about the second one but we did
end up with some we ended up with the
brands and then we got our Redemption
and I guess armenia's last time and then
we crush the summer series so bad if you
look at FAR's results all you see is who
won the knock out Archbishop's
Archbishop's Archbishop's three straight
in a row and we played Montreal at a
very very good time so whoever wrote the
schedule
shoutout to oh my god all the good
people at the protest League the Deputy
Commissioner Isaac Stein camp Nick
Barton JD Cannon and of course we
couldn't have this without the
Commissioner Greg Sahadi so big thanks
to all of them this has been so much fun
and we take it super serious and besides
all this joking matter
and luckily you know the top stars you
know they play for big bucks you know
Wesley Fabiano you know they're on board
there they're bringing out the best of
the team and the best of
yeah it's definitely really interesting
to see all this chest monsters to each
other I really enjoyed watching and be
able to comment on these so what are
your plans so I've already been working
on the you know tea from the dynasty
going I'm already working on the 2020
spreadsheet I'm gonna start sending out
the invitations probably tonight if not
tomorrow or and this is going to be a
great team again a great team again I
have a feeling and hopefully Nikolas
Benjamin Bach and of course the
two-headed monster you know of Wesley so
and Fabiano will be back but you know no
pressure you know I figure out something
with or without them but I hope but it's
a lot easier yeah this was definitely
interesting to watch well I'm glad
everything worked out and this was
really surprising and them we gotta go
celebrate and I do want to give a big
THANK YOU to Grand Master Alejandra
mirrors your chess coach for for you
know recruiting all these great players
to come to st. Louis and making my job
so big thanks to him as well yeah I
thank Alejandra - we have a very good
team this year we always had a good team
and I feel from what I know we are
officially going to have a full girls
team for our Pan Am's oh yeah I don't
common to have specialists in a lot of
the teams don't even have girls so yeah
it's will be very interesting and good
luck you guys home some hardware - st.
Louis it's always a great feeling
thank you very much this is very
interesting and I hope you guys also
enjoy the rest of your day and continue
watching more approaches League and join
us for 2020
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club